election of a Member of Parliament for
Bolton southeast I Roger Hayes being
returning officer the above election do
hereby give notice that number of votes
recorded for each candidate of the said
election is as follows
Armstrong Jeffrey Thomas UK Independence
Party UK 2779 Frank Harris uka Franco
Liberal Democrats 781 Johnson Alan Green
Party 537 poaching Sara Joanne the
Conservative Party candidate 12550
Qureshi Yasmin Labour Party 25
[Applause]
I will repeat that the obviously was
trying out twenty five thousand six
hundred and seventy six the number of
ballot papers rejected was as follows
once of an official mark zero voting for
more candidates from the voter was
entitled to twenty five writing or mark
by which the voter could be identified
one being unmarked or wholly void for
uncertainty 71 and rejecting in part
zero total number of votes cars forty
two thousand four hundred and twenty and
I do hereby declare that Yasmin Qureshi
is duly elected as Member of Parliament
for Bolton
[Applause]
Thank You mr. mayor
firstly I want to thank the emergency
staff and the peace and security staff
and of course the council staff who've
enrolled in the counting and the council
officers who ensure that this election
has been carried out well and they're
all the things expressed smoothly I also
want to pay tribute to my agent or
Hedford and campaign organizer Joe pet
food husband and wife team we've done a
fantastic work to thank all my team and
everyone in the labour party his worked
really really hard to get this good
majority for us and it's really a win
for all of your hard work I also want to
thank my family in particular my husband
the measure for all the support and
health and being there all time for me
my beautiful niece who said in photo
milling and on my brother mother as well
but finally there is one person I want
to pay a particular to beauty and that's
my mother as you know I think most of
you three weeks ago passed away and so
things quieten it difficult campaign in
many ways but the reason I want to pay
tribute because my mother always
believed in me
and all her children and every step of
my life she always encouraged she always
supported she always said never give up
and I miss her truly especially at this
coin at this moment so you know I really
want to say this is for you mom and if
you're watching
and lastly and I say this is a lot of
time this is the last it
thank you I'll do I want you to say it
at the end because I really want to
thank the people of Bolton South East
who have returned me back to Parliament
now for the third occasion I I promise
to keep your faith I promise to serve
and honor you and it's a huge service to
be a member of college of Alton
southeast and again I thank the people
of Alton southeast for voting for me
[Applause]